And I was thinking about this this week too,
cause I was thinking about Noah's Ark and there was a phrase in that story that
I didn't understand,
which was that Noah was perfect in his generations.
I thought,
I don't know what that means.
And you know when you're,
when you're going through a book like the Bible,
if you don't understand a phrase that actually means you've missed something,
it doesn't mean that that's just not,
that's not Germane to the story.
It means you're stupid.
You didn't get it,
man.
You didn't get it.
You didn't understand it.
And so
the idea that Noah was perfect in his generations and that's why he could build
an arc that would sustain him and him and humanity itself through the flood.
It meant that he,
not only did he walk with God,
which is something that we talked about in the context of the sermon on the
mount,
but the,
he established proper relationships with his family,
with his children.
And so what that meant was that his,
not only was he well integrated as a person,
but his level of integration had reached the point where it stretched out beyond
him and encompassed his family.
And so it was Noah and the family that was in the arc.
And I can tell you,
and I really understood this this year because I had a very tumultuous year,
you could think about it from a personal perspective.
I could think about it as a year that had no shortage of floods.
And,
and part of the reason that I was able to get through it,
I also had terrible health problems.
And the only,
one of the reasons I was able to get through it was because my family really
came together around me,
my kids,
my wife,
my parents and my friends as well,
particularly a certain group of friends.
And that's partly all of that came together in my mind this week.
And I thought,
oh,
that's what it means to be perfect in his generations meant that he hadn't just
straightened himself out.
He'd also straightened out to his relationships with his family.
And I can tell you that when crisis strikes you wish it will,
it will.
The flood will come.
Right.
That's why the apocalypse is always upon us.
The flood will definitely come in your life.
And to the degree that you've organized yourself psychologically and also healed
the relationships between you and your family,
that could be the critical element that that determines whether you live or die
when a crisis comes or,
or whether it's someone in your family lives or dies.
And so the idea of the arc containing the man who's who walks with God and whose
generations are perfect and that that's what sustains humanity through the
crisis.
It's like you couldn't be more psychologically accurate than that.
You know?
And the other thing I was thinking about this week,
I,
I was thinking about another line in the new testament.
I think it's from the sermon on the mount,
but I'm not absolutely sure.
Christ compares the Kingdom of Heaven to a mustard seed.
And so I was thinking about it.
Mustard seed is a very tiny seed and it grows into quite a spectacular complex
plant.
And I was thinking about how you should operate in the world in order to make it
a better place,
assuming that that's what you should be doing and that is what you should be
doing.
And there there's lots in the world to fix.
Everything that bothers you about the world and about yourself should be fixed
and you can do that.
And my dawning realization,
I have a friend,
he lives in Montreal,
his name is James Simon.
He's a great painter and he's taught me a lot of things help.
He's helped me design my house and beautify it.
And I bought some paintings from him a couple of years ago.
Um,
and he did this series of paintings where he went around North America and,
and stood in different places and then he painted the view from here down.
And so it's his feet planted in different places on roads in the desert,
on the ocean.
I have one actually hanging over my toilet,
which is him standing at a urinal.
Um,
yeah.
Well,
you know,
he was trying to make a point.
And the point was that wherever you are,
it's worth paying attention.
And that's cause you know,
so all these places that he visited,
he looked at exactly where he was standing by the side of the road in the
desert,
sort of mundane in some sense.
But then maybe he put 40 hours into that painting,
you know,
and it's very,
very realistic painting with really good light.
And what he's telling you as a painter is everything is worth paying attention
to an infinite amount,
but you don't have enough time.
And so the artists does that for you,
right?
The artist looks and looks and looks and looks and looks and then gives you that
vision.
And so then you can look at the painting and it reminds you that,
right where you are is there's every,
everything that there is is right where you are.
And that's a hard thing to realize,
but it's actually true.
And so I've,
I've been telling people online in various ways and in lectures that they should
start fixing up the world by cleaning up the room.
And I wanted to just elaborate on that a little bit before I get back to the
lecture itself.
So I'd say it's become this Internet weird Internet meme,
you know?
Uh,
and,
and it's a joke and good,
it's a joke.
I really happy about the fact that so much of this has got like the leaving of
humor and it's really important because that's what stops things from
degenerating into and to conflict humor.
And I was thinking about this idea of cleaning up your room in relationship to
the mustard seed idea.
And you see the thing about cleaning up your room,
this is also something I learned from Carl Young and his studies on alchemy
because for young,
when the alchemist was attempting to make the philosopher's stone and he was not
only engaged in the transformation of the material world,
but he was engaged in a process of self transformation that occurred at the same
time as the,
as the chemical trend,
as the chemical transformation.
So it was a psychological work in some sense.
Let's say you want to sort out your room and beautified cause the beauty is also
important.
And let's say that all you have is just a little room.
Like you're not rich,
you're poor.
And you don't have any power,
that's another thing,
but you've got your damn room and you've got this space right in front of you.
You know that that's a part of the cosmos that you can come to grips with and
you might think,
well,
what's there in front of you right in front of you?
And the answer to that is,
it depends on how open your eyes are that that's the proper answer because you
could say,
w William Blake said this,
for example,
eldest Huxley made comments that were very similar in a transcendent state.
You can see infinity in the finite and you might say,
well,
you can say,
you can see infinity in what you have within your grasp.
If you look and you could say,
maybe that's the case with your room and so you want to clean up your room.
Well,
okay,
how do you do that?
Exactly?
Well,
the room is a room as a place to sleep.
And so if you set your room up properly,
then you figure out how to sleep and when you should sleep and how you should
sleep.
And then you figure it out when you should wake up.
And then you figure out,
well,
what clothes you should wear because they have to be arranged properly in your
dresser.
And then you have to have some place to put your clothes.
And if you're going to have some clothes,
you have to figure out what you're gonna wear those clothes to do,
right?
And then that means you got to figure out what you're going to do and then your
room has to serve that purpose because otherwise it doesn't set up properly.
And if it doesn't set up,
if it doesn't serve your purposes,
you will be unhappy and not happy in the room.
Because the way that we perceive the world is as a place to move from point a to
point B in.
And then if the place that we're in facilitates that movement,
then we're happy to be there.
And if the place that we're in serves as an obstacle to that movement,
then we're unhappy to be there.
And so what it means to set up your room is that you have to have somewhere to
go that's worthwhile or you can't set up your room and then your room has to be
set up to facilitate that.
And then the next thing is,
well maybe you have to make it beautiful,
but that's not easy,
right?
That means you have to have some taste.
And that doesn't mean you have to have money.
It doesn't because you can be garish with money and you can be tasteful with
nothing.
All you need is taste and taste beats money when it comes to beautifying things,
you know,
I mean not that money is trivial because it's not,
the taste is crucial and people who are very artistically oriented can make
beautiful things out of virtually nothing.
And not only that,
the literature suggests that if you're going to make beautiful things,
putting real constraints on,
on what you allow yourself to do,
facilitates creativity instead of interfering with it.
Because let's say you have to make something out of nothing,
right?
Which I suppose would be a Godly Act,
You have to make something out of nothing and you have to be creative in order
to do that.
And so then to,
to beautify your room means that you also have to develop your capacity to be
creative and so then you can make your room shine,
but then what will happen is that if your family isn't together,
they will interfere with that.
You'll interfere with that because you won't have the discipline to do it
properly.
But then when you start building this,
this,
this little microcosm of perfection with what you have at hand,
and it'll evoke all the pathologies of everyone in your household,
the wonder what the hell you're up to in there and they won't necessarily be
happy because if you're,
if they're in a lowly place,
let's say,
and so are you,
and you're trying to move out of that,
then the,
the higher you move out of that,
the more the place they're in looks bad.
And you might say,
well,
what they should do is celebrate your victory over chaos and evil.
But that isn't what will happen.
What will happen instead is that they will attempt to pull you back down.
They'll attempt to,
and I mean obviously all families still do that,
but,
but all families do that to some degree and some families do almost nothing but
that.
And so what that means is that if you're going to organize your room,
then you're going to have to confront the devils in your house.
And that's often,
that's often a terrifying thing because some of those devils have have lineages
that go back many,
many,
many generations.
And God only knows what you have to struggle with in order to overcome that and
so on.
And so to sort yourself out into fix up your room is a non trivial matter,
you know,
and you can do that.
You'll learn by doing that.
And then maybe you'll learn enough by doing that so that you can fix up your
family a little bit.
And then having done that,
you'll have enough characters so that when you try to operate in the world at
your job,
or maybe in the broader social spheres,
that you'll be a force for good instead of harm because you'll have learned some
humility by noticing just how difficult it was to put your damn room together
well and yourself for that matter.
And so you'll proceed cautiously with your eyes open towards the good.